هل هذا جاكوب ،
نعم ،
إنه رجل باراك أوباما ، هل تتذكرني ،
نعم
تذكر أنك أخبرتني أن
شعرك سيكون رماديًا في المرة القادمة
ولم أكن أكذب
عندما كنت أصغر سنًا ، لقد اعتقدت فقط أن
الرئيس كان مجرد رئيس والدي لم
أفعل  لا أعرف مدى قوته ،
أتذكر نوعًا ما لمس شعره وشعره
الشاهق فوقي ، إنه نوع من الوقوف
هناك ينظر إلي لثانية
ثم يقول
إن شعرك مثل
شعري يسير على ما يرام أه
تريد أن تتحقق وأرى بعد ذلك
انحنى وقلت ، تفضل ، المسها
، وبينما كان يضع يده على
رأس رأسي ،
التقط مصور البيت الأبيض الصورة ،
قلت ما تعتقد أنه يقول ، نعم ،
أعتقد أن هذا
ما لدي الناس إلى حد كبير  من
الأشخاص الخارجيين الملونين الذين ربما لم يشعروا دائمًا
بأنهم ينتمون إلى أنفسهم ، كانوا ينظرون إلى أنفسهم بشكل
مختلف
لرؤية شخص يشبههم
في المكتب البيضاوي إذا رأيت
رجلاً أسودًا آخر في القمة يكون في
ذلك الوقت  أريد أن أتبع ذلك l  اقرأ
جيدًا ، استمع ، أريد أن ألحق بك
لأننا اكتشفنا أنك
ستتخرج هذا الشهر ، أعتقد أن زيارة البيت الأبيض كانت
مصدر إلهام لك ، آمل أن تكون
كذلك حقًا